If this is our hypothesis, we now must devise an experiment to further refine this hypothesis.
Let's come up with a very simple input where we'd assume that this holds.
If we put in just "foo" without any tags, we would assume that we would get the very same output.
Let's do this as an experiment.
Here again, we have a buggy function and now let's conduct the experiment.
So we invoke print-html-markup with foo enclosing double quotes.
We press run and the output is foo, without double quote.
So, now we see the output It's not what we'd expected,
the output being foo without quotes and this again confirm our hypothesis.
We can try this out with even more strings, further strengthening our hypothesis.
So if we put in bar, a very surprising thing is going to happen.
We get bar as output and if we put in just a two quotes,
what we get is an empty string, so we get more failures down the way.
This hypothesis is confirmed now by a number of experiments,
double quotes are stripped from tagged input, but actually we don't even have a new tag
so we can actually scratch that.
Double quotes are stripped from general input.
So even if there's no tags, quotes are being stripped away.
Now we can actually go and explore the cause-effect chain.
If quotes have been stripped away, there must be a place in the code which does that.
The only place in our code where quotes are handled, is right here in this line.
Here we have: if there's a double quote or a single quote and tag is being set
then quote be inverted and when quote is inverted, tags should not be recognized.
Nothing too complicate, but why would the quotes be stripped? Because normally we should not be in tag mode.
Maybe we are in tag mode, maybe the variable tag is set.
So we can come up with a new hypothesis that explains precisely that.